what's your worst sexual experience
it was with a
clown i asked someone you know for
permission for fearless feedback
didn't go well oh my god so that's like
quite a question fearless feedback and
sex sounds like you didn't use a condom
again up here standing ovation people
are like
i don't know
i i had a bad one once when there you
know an act took place a beautiful
gorgeous loving act and then i was
broken up with pretty quickly after
oh so something was performed
something
and someone was performed and so that
was
that was a bad experience for me after
just in terms of sequencing of events
you'd rather be broken up with i think
before so that you can then make a
different choice that's the classy move
yeah
we can't agree we can agree
that if you're gonna do if you if you're
like that's a sociopath that's like i
want to break up with casey but i'm also
a little bit randy
um i do remember hearing the story and
you left out that first part on the you
know the first telling of it and it was
dark and then it got
a lot darker
a lot darker but you know everything's
great for me now i feel really good
about
where i'm at and
she's doing great she's doing great you
guys no worries
everything's good hey baby girl
what's going on i'm okay yeah yeah i'm
okay sorry
i'm good i'm good i'm good
she's back